hey ok so now I'm I'm going to begin by
talking about computational learning
I'll mention a few models of learning
that people have studied in theoretical
computer science in machine learning and
then talk about how to relate to what I
did in the previous one hour so so the
basic question here is learning from
data learning from examples so let X be
some space so like what we have in the
previous which is maybe some either this
one through ten some multi-level
variables for each exercise in either
billion real value this some
distribution d of x and and in this the
first model that will talk about this
notion of an example or ago so what the
stresses think of this is a black box so
you have a learning algorithm that has
access to this black box and each time
you the learning algorithm ask for Quake
you get an example X and F X f of X
where F is some target function X is
drawn from this distribution
so this is this clear what's happening
it at end so you have a learning
algorithm that task is to learn some
unknown function if and again we think
that if comes from some class of
functions and then the question is for
what class of functions can we actually
learn it from data and this is so this
is the probably approximately probably
approximately correct framework reduce
violence valiant in peace and maybe I'll
be less precise in the definitions now
but this sees is fat learnable f is
learnable if there exists a learning
algorithm rhythm if such that for every
F&F every day over X epsilon greater
than 0 SE with access to this example
block black box
outputs some prediction rules and
hypotheses X from the things 1 1 such
that probability high probability the
error of H is defined to be the
probabilities under d f of X is not
equal to H of X it's maybe a possibility
for monday but so this is what we mean
by learning so there's a class of
functions you have access to labeled
examples from this and we say this class
is learnable if you if there's an
algorithm that no matter what function
is chosen from this class if it has
access to labeled examples from this it
outputs the hypothesis such that the
error of this hypothesis is small with
respect of the target function it and
first we want running time to be
polynomial in n + 1 waves q case it just
it just queries ok so it asks it does
for an example but it just ask for rams
on what can I so I would like an example
like this so you can construct you can
hear you can define such a model that's
more powerful than this but I really
don't want to get into that it's called
the membership query model so you can
construct your own x and ask what the
label of that x is just what is where
just a random thought so here you get a
ton in example x is drawn from the
situation be here
okay and the first observation just is
that at any F that's evolvable is also
pack level and and this is because
everything I said in the previous talk
you can simulate if you have access to
this article so you can you can know
about the in particular performances you
can run the mutation algorithms on so so
this is here and this why why it should
be clear okay yeah so okay so let's
remember what I said about evolvability
last time so we had this class of
representations each representation
could be evaluated in polynomial time
there was this mutation algorithm that
also could be simulated in polynomial
time so i can start with any
representation run the mutations compute
what the empirical performances were
because i have access to this example
okay so your reservation would be my
current record yes yeah that's your
current hypothesis and you know that in
a small number of generations you will
get a hypothesis that is close to
optimal so it's exactly the same manner
that probably this agreement is the site
yeah yeah yeah okay so this probability
of a disagreement is exactly related
this is 1 minus the correlation so these
for boolean functions this is for
boolean functions so f is f is still
boolean so excise can be FS movie
okay so okay so this observation is here
and the question would be that is it
also true that anything that's back
learnable can be evolved and the answer
is going to be no and to show that I'll
actually define yet another model of
learning which is more restrictive than
this Oh which is the statistical query
model and this was introduced by my guns
maybe 90 and okay so here there is no
example Oracle so this is going to be
learning algorithm but it it has a
different way of accessing the target
function and actually the description
that i'm going to give right now is the
shootie and vitali fireman's here so so
there's a different Oracle which let me
call it the stat Oracle which the
learning algorithm can make two kinds of
queries to this so the first kind of
query is it has function parameter tau
and then maybe it says string fidelity
stay I'll get independent and and what
okay so what is G so G is some function
from the space X 2 minus 11 so it can be
real valued function it doesn't matter
much if you restrict you to be a boolean
function or a real valued function and
what you get as a response is the answer
is some V in minus 11 with a guarantee
that the expectation of G of X minus
fees at noise
right so so you don't get to see any
examples that you don't get to see what
your space is even but for any statistic
that we can define on this space you can
you know what it is approximately so
that's the first kind of clay and its
target independent because it has
nothing to do with the target function
yet ok the second kind of fairy is oh
yeah sorry Thanks ok so this expectation
is for example from the distribution tea
do you want to learn with respect the
second way is n it has G entao but this
is actually correlational NGS is some
function from this and this time the
answer is going to be some feel that the
expectation of 50 and this time it's the
correlation between G of X and f of X it
so so the second kind of queries I come
up with some pumpkin gee I want to learn
approximately what the correlation of G
is with respect to F so
it's just something to stick on the
distribution there's nothing to do with
the target so you want to know what the
mean of X is what so tau can be chosen
by a learner but the restriction on tau
is that it has to be sat on has to be
greater than some inverse polynomial in
n + 1 over Epsilon so you cannot demand
arbitrarily good accuracy or for these
statistics so G is how the function you
trying to deliver JS my queries f is the
target function f is right sir thank you
SI sorry where is f'd gone in the case 1
so the first there is no if so what is
just it's just to learn about the
distribution so oh sorry okay so yeah so
the algorithm doesn't know what the
distribution is the access to the
distribution in two cases through these
kinds of ways and
and what and so this observation here
can actually be strengthened likely
which is actually that also that any f
that's SQ learnable so any F that's
evolvable is also SQ learnable SQ
learnable is a subset of fact SQ
learnable is a subset of patentable and
the reason for this is if you have it
you can simulate these this oracle if
you have access to examples right and
and if you remember the definition of
evolution that I get you only care about
the performance it's really these kinds
of ways that you need approximately and
that's that those are sufficient to
simulate the evolutionary process and so
anything that's evolvable is also asked
you learn about now ask you what it was
about watch mobile animal so that's open
to some great actually Battaglia is an
expert and that's he would so one
example we
so there's one example we know we travel
to see and anything else that we know
somehow relates to this one example
so what is this class of functions that
cannot be london-based q Mazel so this
is the theorem that due to Michael
Kern's since that the class of parodies
and it will define what parodies is in a
second is not ask you learn what this
parrot is so let let me say that X is
minus 1 1 to the N again and parities
this function was the one for every
subset of in this parity function which
is defined this just the product of the
bits in the subset so these are all
minus 11 valued variables and look at
the subset I I take the product of all
the exercise in that subset if an odd
number of them r minus 1 then this is
minus 1 if an even number of them r
minus 1 then it's the answer is 1 so you
have the student the N possible parity
functions so this is a class of
functions and this cannot be learnt in
this schema so this is so this shows
that it's a SQ is is weaker than pack 1
and also that means this class is not
about people in the sensory to school ok
snob ok I mean it's kind of obvious not
entirely obvious you can think of this
as as a system of linear equations over
field of size 2 so so para trees so
that's why you can solve them because
it's a fetus design but it's got an
elimination
it took so
so theorem actually I don't know baby
this its folklore okay that despite
learn about it someone is the paper okay
so parity is this packing on and it's
not SQL okay and so we can actually now
demonstrate that there's a class that's
you know you're not a vault open and
maybe in some sense it's it I don't know
if it's a good thing it's not surprising
that this class is not evolve if you
don't want some functionality to depend
on you don't expect some functionality
depend on whether or not an order even
number of certain inputs are active or
not
yeah you're saying but there aren't a
whole lot of other other admirable
examples on school examples which sort
of some house one wishes one could hope
I'm so so they are and but they're okay
so they're all related to this in some
way or the other so for example you can
make up the class with dnf expressions
but not a skewed a little bit what is
that so the NF expressions is oars of
ends some conjunction inside and you
have a disjunction of a number of them
and each so they could be this could be
long in the total number of them could
also be there not ask you learnable so
some other the carry one positive it's a
strong part is strongly dependent on
each of the variables as you could get
right and the other song which sort of
lively would seem to have that
properties are very strongly dependent
variable is horrible
so I think I think the answer is is no
but I don't have a straight i mean
there's very few things that are you
actually do know i rescued an apple
given outside of this but could you
maybe give me intuition for the proof
for why do you think don't ask you okay
yeah maybe yeah so so guess I'll be
brief about that so the point is think
of this as suppose you have a uniform
distribution on and on minus 112 again
okay so so what we have is that all of
these parity functions 2 to the N of
them they all bought the normal with
respect to each other's so if thanks
this is there correctly uncorrelated and
another point is this this if you have
if you get only some information about
so you can only ask these kinds of quays
up to some tolerance so there's no point
in these kinds of queries because you
know even the distribution and so each
such where he actually gives you really
little information about the parity that
you're looking for because this 2 to the
N of them and all of them are as
uncorrelated as you can possibly have in
this space and which means that your
queries are quite uninformative so you
have to make a large number of them to
get any information about this hidden
parity there is no need to be the quest
don't need to be pirate or puke ways but
you're saying that no matter what they
are right so okay so the penalties form
a basis so you can write it G in terms
of the spaces and so you get off you
totally blew the right one if you if you
don't include the right one you don't
get yeah if your query already doesn't
have some correlation with the target
Paratore then you don't get so that's
done that shows that
yeah I think I think it's chilly you can
show that 6 2 to the n over log endless
some large number of ways it's not just
put another so any more questions okay
so just by knowing that the first
comment already know there are lots of
possible which are not sure that these
things you can be on things the other
thing even thinks some things you should
know how to learn no yeah yeah so do you
believe that there are things which are
askew learnable but not all and so they
are and so that's so case I don't want
to go into the details is a little bit
this is maybe a couple of subtle points
a bit so if you if you think of
simulating an evolution process right so
so what do we need so so the only place
where the target function comes in is
when we are modeling natural selection
somewhere right so we want to selection
with respect to the performance of your
representation with respect to the
actual target ideal function and that's
just the correlation between the two of
these and so you want what you to
simulate evolution what you need is an
approximate quantity which is something
that approximates the performance of
your representation which is just the
correlation of your representation with
the target and you're allowed to make
these queries so right so this this
gives you something that's very much
like the empirical performance and so
you can using these you can simulate
this
um should we be one and this okay send
this sort of an even stronger
restriction on learning model which is
just introduced by vitaliy Feldman this
is this correlation of statistical
quality model so this is stronger than
statistical quiz but weaker than pack a
smaller yes I'm gonna come hey I'm
coming to that it so this is okay so the
next one is correlational it's a this
correlation is king so which is
basically the same as SQ but you're only
allowed to make queries of the second
time SQ with only correlation in place
okay so so you're in this learning model
but you don't know the distribution your
your learning algorithm has to work with
respect to every distribution but the
only access you have is you don't get
cloths you two sticks about the
distribution directly you can only learn
anything you can about the distribution
by asking queries that what is the
correlation of my function with the
target so that's the restriction and and
again I mean so the similarity solution
is clear that you only need these kinds
of queries it so we never really needed
this so so the observation is also that
anything that's evolvable is also c SQ
learnable
esq no no and we did help yeah okay so
okay so let me do that right now and so
what we know is that you have this
evolved yeah this is hieu which is so in
it this pack and and so one what vitaly
showed is that CS q is actually the same
as evolvability so it was a Volvo with
respect to a specific distribution okay
so good so that's okay so night thanks
for catching me on that yes so if you if
you require the definition of evolution
to work for all distributions this is
true and if you fix the distribution
this is true up up to us an issue called
as uniformity versus non uniformity in
the model of computation which I don't
want to get into but I'm happy to talk
to you after this distribution then you
is if if you fix the distribution or you
are only one triple evolvability with
respect to that distribution then these
sqn evolvability is the same and if you
want your evolutionary process to
succeed no matter what the distribution
is then evolution and CS gives the same
if you have gotta make your excuse yeah
so I guess I guess it's good so when you
say the fix distribution doesn't know
that is so that's sort of the okay so
that's why this question of the model of
computation comes into the picture so so
the way I defined it is that there
exists a class of representations the
representations were allowed to be
polynomially long so if I fix the
distribution what i can do is i can take
a large sample from the distribution say
some polynomials lies ahead of time and
encode that in my representation for
everything in this for every organism
and now i can answer these queries
directly and it is that respect that so
which makes okay it was clear to any
otherwise find me after the doc which
okay for is illusory one sounds bizarre
cheating right so right so that's the
thing set and once you define the thing
you can make this formal statement
okay and music ways you could say that
the stuff that's available to evolution
it's a class that's available with
respect to the particular distribution
that exists in the world of environments
and then there's maybe you know some
other distributions that could have
happened that would have made all the
functions that we actually see nann
evolvable but that doesn't really matter
okay so I care about the idea of the
actual functions I see in the world and
then those are available with respect to
the actual distribution of environments
that existed and they may be totally
unavailable compared to some other
distribution environments that didn't
exist but someone was the first part
which is evolving the transcription and
translation of general structure which
is the bit which is the somehow the
working with some distribution of stars
forming to the actual Thank You
environment yes
make sure that was created through
revolution right okay so how that's a
different question how do you even model
the environment but it's actually this
is which I mean I didn't want to start
the discussion that but at this point I
let me state negate just a couple of
other results which so it's so so there
is it is not let c SQ is there indeed
classes in SQ that are not in CS q which
is resolved if you photographer Gwynn
and in fact even a very simple class
which is the class of conjunctions that
are defined the first but is so
conjunctions are not in CS q if we want
an algorithm that uses only correlation
queries to succeed in learning
conjunctions under any distribution
there is no CSK algorithm that can do it
in polynomial time
guys seriously interested yeah yes
definition with your story could you
define a contraction yeah i can define a
conjunction yeah ok so the conjunction
is good a bit to find exactly like
priorities since for every subset
there's a conjunction yes p sub set and
n and s is
to all of so every written this has to
be one that's it is so these are
monotone conjunctions you could also add
them allow negations for some of them
you could have negations and some of
them is norma kitchen so so for any
subset you can define a conjunction for
that and for every variable you can
either allow include the variable itself
or its negation in the community some of
it is part of difficulty in doing these
is that it's all it's usually zero no
it's not so once you move beyond the
uniform distribution that's not actually
the case so you can define distributions
where conjunctions can be zero and
non-zero quite often it's you know I
still look up right and that's actually
crucial I mean if it's if it were the
uniform distribution then you can but of
course this definition of c SQ doesn't
make sense because you know that you're
working in the uniform distribution then
you or anything that you can get here
but you can get it for free you had
short conjunctions then it would be
so it's a depend on how short any
constant yes but that's if you have a
constant size conjunctions there's only
polynomially many of them you can try
all of them one of them will give you
the correct answer for this correlation
these are just a cytosolic should be
putting on all over bosses and one of
Rex's only says that it's hard if you
wanted to learn it to very high accuracy
okay I can't be even relatively short it
can be done just a little bit yeah
the only in short ones like look and
which is much smaller
okay so whether that's what they I'm
intrigued by your comment that
biologically we only have four queda
conjunction that's why you just proved
it right I mean I you made a negative
comment but is also positive comment
biologically we have conjunctions really
so you know what other function is one
of the aspects this model do we see in
biology so this is talking about soon
yeah okay so actually let me stop with
this one and I'll ask this question so
do we know what functions are computed
by biology so let's go back to this
picture that I still have so if you look
at say transcription network you have a
protein that's being produced so how
many transcription factors do we know
affect the production of a single
protein do we know what the expression
level looks like as a function of
concentration of other layer which
transcription factors are active
concentration level as other things and
so on so but not actually that so this
is like what for example you know I
believe that you find it out that
experimental is fine that the
prescription is much more complicated
many factors like sometimes the
they getting the center of a new clothes
and a corrugated is able to do and so on
there seems to be no no boundaries how
complicated this one goes well for a
single site there's there's a
transcription factors combined they do
form these complexes mature but then you
go upstream to see what regulates those
transcription factors yes okay but this
is actually one whether they're very
interesting scaling observation which is
if you look at bacteria mm-hmm and you
look at the number of transcription
factors as a function number of genes in
the genome okay and over a whole range
which is basically two orders of
magnitude in genome like the bacteria
the number of transcription factors goes
as the square of the number of genes in
the genome and so the way the bacteria
regulates which is a much more to Mystic
way than this combinatory ways I'll do
you know you know we know more about
bacterial regulation all right but yeah
but this is just observation this is
just a particular data but if you just
do a naive extrapolation and you say
okay I'm a bacterial genome that three
times as big if the biggest ones that
exist it would be ultra scription
package so that does seem to be
something which is the bacteria from
other major innovations of eukaryotes
was doing this regulation in a very
different way this is so much to say you
think so
so using this for each protein there's a
single transcription factor in bacteria
this responsible for regulating is but a
small number for each one is not used
multiple times each one is obviously I
see video well understand some of our
regulation bacteria not everything but
the scaling law is pretty convincing I
mean a lot of powerful or you look at it
okay well it's not much great this one
is pretty convincing and it's a stronger
one than any other properties of the and
if you look at singles that would you
care if you don't know with a lot of
single-cell multi so you added 11
transcription factor binding site and
then there is a limit to the number of
transcription factors invited at one
side but then each gene has you on this
number of binding sites also write in
terms of enhancer said upstream is it
here in your function you don't have
that X is then that function of Y I mean
you don't have feedback so the feedback
that's piling up in the actual
biological thing as far as I see it's
not in the water
yeah so okay so that's okay so that's
another question that I want to just so
a so upstream said for a single protein
is it then how many transcription
factors honest okay said maybe you have
pictured right so cascading is so
cascading could could very well be
included in this right because some of
these excise could produce some other
protein and which in terms with some
other excess we produce some other
protein and so on what you care about is
the final result and that's so this so
this functional representation does
capture cascading but that's okay so
that's another question that we were
sort of interested in to hug do we find
these cats keds of large debts or you
know so do you have long casts skater or
they are usually short and it seems to
be the case from what i try to read that
for transcription networks these casts
kids are not that long because
transcription takes time and if you if
the cell wants to divide it doesn't it
doesn't have that much time to keep
having these long runs non cascades
something but okay so these are actually
precise is the kind of questions that so
they have yeah there's definitely have
longer cascades than bacteria do
research on that and first of all the
cask is a huge absolutely huge what you
also have our hottest known as a
phenomenon which is done in NC be here
cause for all costs holly berries in
which you have all the transcription
factors already found on the sides and
it just requires that RNA polymerase to
start off so the developmental event
would be this is starting off so the
transcription factors are all there so
there is no time delay in the binding of
the transcription factors on the sex
over there no but the production of
protein itself right so i mean you have
RNA polymerase transcribing and then
they have ribosome translating from an
mrna into this the whole process to
produce enough quantities of protein to
further influence the downstream
reaction it takes time right it's not
it's ten taneous
yeah in the computer science okay so
what what are the numbers actually sir
yeah so was i I guess I'm even for
numbers it would be like is it 8 10 20
what's what are the kind of yeah that's
right a one complex of transcription
factors on just the promoter sequence of
the gene would be on the order of 50
okay but then again you have a lot of
DNA that sauce goes back on itself and
give these other regulatory elements for
enhancers and inhibitors which again has
its own set of transition the whole
thing the whole machinery which is also
known as a transcription factor wouldn't
be anywhere between 250 at the same time
I meaning it for the same time position
of transcription factors and for
transcription factors only at the
promoter okay and forget about the other
regulatory elements that hook back and
roots back onto the I'm dropping my
buddy my buddy said oh you can you
really think all 15 transcription
factors are operating at the thing
however their digital at different times
in the development of
given transcription & transcription
factors to public oh yes oh there's
definitely other things besides
registration factors but like the number
of relevant variables at any particular
time is actually something very
interested in yeah handsome yeah but the
bacterial example is oh it's quite a lot
simpler um and and something that was
leasing the vague class think it's not
like bacteria that would be a huge
progress maybe we don't understand your
carrier invisible players we should
understand the bacteria one at least
some reasonable level understand again
it's not nearly as complicated and
listen to be lamento seemed she somehow
it can't do overfill the complex things
right but ok so just sticking to
something like bacteria it's the kind of
questions they were interested in even
is so against all so translate what is
the context now that you are what kind
of grapes I want you I want to know what
kind of a sphere interested in can we
you know and even other questions how do
they really do how many variables do
they really dependent upon I mean so we
know that there it is a wonder of
hundreds of transcription factors
present in the cell but maybe for a
single event there's only a few of them
that actually involved in the
transcription for particular protein and
how does evolution find the circuit is
it if you if you know that this function
depends on your few number of variables
can evolution to create faster please
and so these are the kind of questions
that we want stand and I think this this
framework that are described in the
previous are actually offers a offers a
way to actually start answering these
kinds of questions and if you if I tell
you that this if depends on a small
number of variables indeed you may be
able to divorce faster than if it didn't
kinds of questions
ok so this s'okay another question that
we would be interested in this so
transcription is just one system where
what are the other kinds of systems that
you know people would care about and can
we it would look like some functional
representations in what got a volley
better be most well F is the fixed point
of some weird function
sssa would put what do you mean so you
might as well so this is not a
biological functions a pagerank is a
fixed point on a certain process between
again I'll show I get the point I mean
thinks that battle just would actually
care about them so the temple is
interesting that you turn into linear
programming problems and claiming
congrats optimizations its own
understanding and that's it you know
it's one it has a reasonable idea what
the functions are the relevant so it's
okay it's not very nice class okay she
is more detail yeah but yeah whatever
metabolism function with a fight or
diagram should we have in our heads
which things you can eat and what you
commit which chemicals chemicals a
little things you read and then very
seem to make which some everything makes
and other ones into a factor of eight
others done so your input outputs and
you have to do the right things overall
range of concentrations of the input
Oh
yes is this bud maybe 13 or so minutes
left so I would love to continue this
discussion if people have more questions
or if anyone is really curious i could
try and sketch why this result is true
hey vice esq can be cast as an
evolutionary algorithm but it was
interested in just trying to discuss
what kinds of systems we could look at
and how we could look at it I think that
would be definitely something that's of
interest to first n yeah I'm sure you
know all of them but Paul valiant
photographers min Elena and restless
valiant er I am definitely contributed
greatly to all of this work and and all
of them would be here some more part of
the time the semester so we're in
trouble I have you ever tried to imagine
what the world would be if evolution had
a party to go to preparing the Oracle
so how do you defeat that your inner so
we won't be the function it seems like
you have X's the answers are fixed and
then they don't like
themselves the exes are like the
external environment yeah so that you
can do whatever you want them once you
bring me and safe but you have like a
system a system of functions to be right
so okay it's okay so that me trying to
be a bit more precisely so it's a
feedbacks in the in the network itself
are okay as long as a final output is
stable I mean if the final output is
time dependent then this model doesn't
necessarily capture this but just having
feed so there's all these kinds of these
regulatory networks that have feedback
there but a lot of the time that these
are useful only it is stabilized quickly
or in other a different levels what the
final output that you care about it is
but in which case that's completely
captured by this kind of a setting but
if there's actually time varying
quantities of y which so things like you
want a clock in the cell or something so
this this wouldn't necessarily capture
that model but so I've read a couple
papers where they kind of conceptualized
some of this as you have a imagining of
a cell and there are all the protein
concentrations of each of those
correspond to some axis the high
dimensional space and the behavior of
the cell traces out some kind of
manifold or shape over time there's it's
stochastic but it has some kind of
recurrent behavior and
you know they frame like cell
differentiation or something is like
going from you know you're kind of going
around a circle here or do you kind of
go around circle there and if you look
at for instance vaginal microbiome data
where you know you're this bacteria
these bacteria or can sit are in like a
dynamic community you see kind of that
behavior where they're these little
twirls then it could you just you'd put
it in like you project it down into like
three dimensions whatever making video
and that you kind of see this manifold
like behavior
and you just say is there any way that
could kind of be folded in
because if we see if I understand people
yeah yeah yeah I think I think of the
Metro microbiome there's like four visit
etra view dream the area for knee has
this
the animation
but in terms of like what the system is
probably like and then figure out like
how to follow that I just just an
observation it's like an hour lecture so
Eric stitches look at something where
it's phenotypic evolution associate Lee
development to try to find a large
number of fixed points and how the fix
bifurcate from each other and so on and
so maybe one of the cost problems
initiative to look at but I guess having
objected to come often objecting to
doing worst-case analysis there is
another from kitchen pocket I think it
was raised here is that people one
usually thinks all of us being the
fitness after jump environment is being
the relevant thing but the most crucial
thing is already extinction and so that
in some ways the you want the
probability that you end up doing badly
integrator over sometime of the
something environment to be as low as
possible so it's a solid different
optimization and this the Venice may be
at least of an important
okay but it is I think that this is so
it's okay so there's lots of things that
are important in the mission is a by no
means old and I think the question we
were really want to try and answer is
can we get this question how does
complex novelty arise later mean this is
this is what we do we have an
explanation for this I think this is
this is it so this okay so each each
function class actually is a measure of
complexity right sir so I defined a
couple of function that i can define
more other classes in each of some of
them are more complex and others and and
what we want to do is try and delineate
the the class of functions that you
makes expect to see in the world because
evolution can succeed and others that
you can do share that you would not find
it like the class of parities and so
this is and this is the so in in some
ways his way of viewing this which I our
separate this from what other people
work on this area have been saying but
my personal take on this is that many of
these results may be viewed negatively
so that you know what we have
characterizing this picture which again
the other people work on this do not
agree with but this is essentially
saying that um this is so perhaps your
complaint is that nobody's function
classes actually looked at Tom complex
not as complex as these complicated
time-dependent interactions one way of
looking at this is just well okay so
complex on complexity can to rise by
evolution in the fixed environment so
any kind of complicated thing that
happens in a cellar it in some
multicellular organism couldn't have
evolved from the fixed environment has
to be the result of multistage evolution
as the environment changed and as
as a result ecological effects or some
multistage process all th kerala process
but hopes of different things are going
home in different environments yeah yes
so what are we looking at this is it you
know one punch line which again is
controversial is that this is just
saying that nothing complicated can
arise in a fixed environment so that's
we need to look at other explanations
for how anything I'll get involved so
that you know the computational view of
this is saying that in fact evolution is
much more challenging than we had
appreciated and that anything
non-trivial that we see in a creature
must have evolved by some multistage
process for instance that ecology is
essentially you might that's one rep
relationship so I sort of clarify that a
bit so when you say something complex
can evolve to your friend in the state
in a valley yeah but that's a that's a
worst-case same advice that says or
maybe abroad this is you exist that you
know you know in sexual advances if you
have that function process soluble so
that we still be easy is this is a PMF
that are a butt and again i'm certainly
not saying that dnf for parodies don't
exist in life um very calm kid functions
exist in cells just if these things
exist in cells then the explanation
either needs to be that it's a
particularly simple instance this
instance of this kind of thing or that
it arm evolved in multiple stages
whether it's not perhaps perfectly
adapted to to to its learned the
conjunction work if I sort of comment
that the tally made it did it's only
barely non polynomial so if it's into
the log one of excellence then that's
something where he is not polynomial
pick up the dilution appropriate
actually there are other ways to bypass
this this lower bound by just along your
outfit to be not just boolean button
being some value to them say nice one
and one and have the fitness depend on
how close or a little I don't know maybe
okay yeah maybe I should yeah but is
this there are some it's not kind of
fight yellow study better day yeah so
this okay so maybe I should thanks for
reminding me I should talk about the sir
so you can ask all these questions when
what happens when these functions are
not boolean right so you want to try and
live all functions that look like maybe
they even from RM RM and this is
actually Falls Road and so you can ask
so so once you start defining functions
that are not boolean anymore you have to
define what you mean by performance and
it's a lot more settled right so you can
have several notions of performance and
so for example one possible way but view
this would be that under the
distribution square error of this should
be so now this is more like a loss
rather than a performance right and and
even if even if the function that you
are available evolving is buggin you can
ask what happens whether if the
representation that you use is actually
allowed to output real valued numbers
and not boolean function that it gets
feedback that's actually richer than
just what you would if you viewed it as
a boolean function and once you said
allowing these things then you do get
more classes that are evolved for
example you can avoid conjunctions and I
mean if you think of F is real valued
functions what you so suppose sure that
you can as long as this loss function
that you are using here is is complex
you can
so any function that looks like a low
degree polynomial to something that's
very less something of the sort you can
indeed expect evolution to succeed on
these kinds of things and the reduction
there is is again it's along the lines
of this converting a particular class of
optimization algorithm the cussing them
is evolutionary mechanisms it described
in the last talk and okay so so you do
get sort of Richard classes once you
allow men to move beyond boolean
functions and boolean feedback
and one of the questions we believe the
bully are not continuous is the genome
users are digital but all phenotypes
beginning for proteins on up our videos
variables and so there's an issue does
it actually matter the fact that the
genomes are basically digital or should
be right away say okay really this
continuous variables with a microscopic
scale and one has a microscopic where's
the proximate of those of the discrete
set of numbers I'm in there and that
relates issues you know how big genes
are at all whether it's sort of market
to immediately say we're going to go to
everything being containers variables or
whether it's crucial that I assess I
mean the question is also the
performance metric that what makes sense
is digital or a boolean break I mean for
you know so the production of quantities
of protein might look like it's a
continuous variable but the question is
does it matters at yo I just want to
surpass a particular threshold or
whether it's it's actually the actual
number gives measures and this is the
cancer center of me normally they're
both kinds
for what people think our members
but the ones with small numbers gray
stochastic as you're ever doing the
solution of those in the end of
everything is different I think there
are lot of aspects of the fitness we're
just looking inequalities no bigger than
this is good and that it doesn't matter
how much it seems they usually I mean
smaller than this depending how much
smaller your different levels of badness
no baby once you get bigger than you can
wander all over its patients make bigger
than that the more don't think of as
well yeah register but I mean even
without any kind of like pathway effects
or anything that sort you're going to
have a dependence of protein concentrate
like the fitness is going to depend on
protein concentration group because
protein abundance is and protein
stabilities are going to affect like
unfolded protein toxicity in a Cell
and that's actually really important
that we share a factor
so you mentioned that this string fixed
environment so this shows that you can't
evolve these complex functions we fix it
environment so we assume that the axes
are fixed whether the distribution is
fixed the distribution of X is fixed and
and the district target is also fixed it
you can't imagine the VX is changing in
time but if you look at them at some
time it's like you're changing targets
the distribution a question is this this
is all assuming a thick setbacks or fix
distributions it's a Pyxis tribution so
if everything except this is a fixed
distribution of X's are the robustness
of this album if you can start menu
presentation and converge a tent from
any point to the target so if your
target or distribution anything changes
given you really have a distribution in
it like your
the lubrication em algorithm is can
evolve the class for any distribution
then particularly the distribution
changes it will just start going towards
the new target